how the heck did life originate on earth
yeah well maybe we i'll come to that in
a second but i think the ultimate use of
ai is to
kind of use it to accelerate science to
the maximum so i um think of it a little
bit like the tree of all knowledge if
you imagine that's all the knowledge
there is in the universe to attain and
uh we sort of barely scratched the
surface of that so far in even though
you know we've we've done pretty well
since the enlightenment right as
humanity and i think ai will turbo
charge all of that like we've seen with
alpha fold and i want to explore as much
of that tree of knowledge as it's
possible to do and um and i think that
involves ai helping us with with with
understanding or finding patterns um but
also potentially designing and building
new tools experimental tools so i think
that's all uh
and also running simulations and
learning simulations all of that we're
already we're sort of doing it at a at a
at a you know baby steps level here but
i can imagine that in in in the decades
to come as uh you know what's the full
flourishing of of that line of thinking
it's going to be truly incredible i
would say if i visualize this tree of
knowledge something tells me that that
knowledge for tree of knowledge for
humans is much smaller
in the set of all possible trees of
knowledge it's actually quite small
given our cognitive
limitations
limited cognitive capabilities that even
with with the tools we build we still
won't be able to understand a lot of
things and that's perhaps what
non-human systems might be able to reach
farther not just as tools
but in themselves understanding
something that they can bring back yeah
it could well be so i mean there's so
many things that that that are sort of
encapsulated in what you just said there
i think first of all um there's there's
two different things there's like what
do we understand today yeah what could
the human mind understand and what is
the totality of what is there to be
understood yeah right and so there's
three consensus you know you can think
of them as three larger and larger trees
or exploring more branches of that tree
and i i think with ai we're going to
explore that whole lot now the question
is is
you know if you think about what is the
totality of what could be understood um
there may be some fundamental physics
reasons why certain things can't be
understood like what's outside the
simulation or outside the universe maybe
it's not understandable from within the
universe
so that's there may be some hard
constraints like that you know it could
be smaller constraints like
we
think of space-time as fundamental for
us our human brains are really used to
this idea of a three-dimensional world
with time right
maybe but our tools could go beyond that
yeah they wouldn't have that limitation
necessarily they could think in 11
dimensions 12 dimensions whatever is
needed but um we could still maybe
understand that in several different
ways the example i always give is um
when i you know play gary kasparov at
speed chess or we've talked about chess
and these kind of things um you know he
if you if you if you're reasonably good
at chess you can um you can't come up
with the move gary comes up with in his
move but he can explain it to you and
you can understand and you can
understand post hoc the reasoning yeah
so so i think there's a there's an even
further level of like well maybe you
couldn't have invented that thing but
but using that going back to using
language again perhaps you can
understand and appreciate that same way
like you can appreciate you know vivaldi
or mozart or something without you can
appreciate the beauty of that without um
being able to to construct it yourself
right invent the music yourself so i
think we see this in all forms of life
so it'll be that times you know
a million but it would you can imagine
also one sign of intelligence is the
ability to explain things clearly and
simply right you know people like
richard feynman another one of my
all-time heroes used to say that right
if you can't you know if you can explain
it something simply then you that's a
that's the best sign a complex topic
simply then that's one of the best signs
of you understanding it yeah so i can
see myself talking trash in the ai
system in that way yes uh
it gets frustrated how dumb i am and
trying to explain something to me i was
like well that means you're not
intelligent because if you were
intelligent you'd be able to explain it
simply yeah of course you know there's
also the other option of course we could
enhance ourselves and and without
devices we we are already sort of
symbiotic with our compute devices right
with our phones and other things and you
know this stuff like neural link and
etcetera that could be could could
advance that further um so i think
there's lots of lots of really amazing
possibilities that i could foresee from
here
you